[Music]
and me Glow for the best TV host goes to
carly steal a well-deserved award Carly
well that is just because you were not
there Annette Oh battery will get you
everywhere but um I know what she was
really doing right there you were
actually giving Sylvester Stallone's
daughter which is very nice if you a
chance to rehearse before Sunday's go to
global well it is a big night for them
Nancy they're gonna be up on stage
giving worse to some of the biggest
stars in Hollywood and just maybe even
becoming stars themselves who's more
nervous you guys are your parents about
100 percent normally because they're
giving us so much advice and they're
just worried if we mess up or truth fist
alone sisters Sophia cysteine and
Scarlett are getting ready to make
history for the first time ever there
will be not one but three miss golden
blow your dad Golden Globe winner is
going to be on stage presenting can we
look forward to any special family
moment if you talked about maybe doing
something with your dad I hope we do
something else stage with him it's gonna
be an amazing night we also got a sneak
peek at the seating cards inside the
ballroom ahead of Sunday's show at one
table presenter and nominee Justin
Timberlake is just one seat away from
fellow nominee and former Mickey Mouse
Club buddy Ryan Gosling someone slides
daughters are hoping to present an award
to there might be some hair pulling some
claws coming out rock paper scissors or
what
otherwise I think Boop you was a little
one you don't get a say yeah is who
that's how we call it any interest in
following in your dance footsteps any hi
tried it dad work out maybe it didn't
work out how old are you fourth grade
fourth grade I did a movie and let's
just say I didn't know my line
it was Lully forward they had to cut it
they had to cut my line and a half so I
wouldn't mess up so let's just say none
of us got the acting gene